I've been playing with computers and
electronics for a very
young age
and what I've learned over the year is
that the ability to take technology and
turn it into something
viable functional that people want and
need and solves people's life
is what excites me sounds a little bit
like a cliche but seeing lots of people
use your technology and get excited
about it use your product actually is
what excites me welcome to 20 minute
leaders just sit back relax and learn
from the leaders of today it's a journey
each one is different unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
I have the pleasure of speaking to a
technologist at heart an entrepreneur
and today investor by profession and so
a really really cool Journey disrupting
some some really interesting Industries
with solar Edge and and the different
things you've done in the military and
today obviously working in and investing
with one of the you know the the really
I think you were just named one of the
best funds in the world from the
entrepreneur side which is which is
really awesome that's probably the most
important metric out there sort of like
the NPS of the of the traditional you
know customers and so I'm really happy
to have you here lior tell me a little
bit about your passions you know why you
know what really excites you in in your
world
so so I I love the the term Technologies
at heart because I've been doing
technology stuff in the very very
very early stage
my first computer I got it at the age of
seven
had one kilobyte of memory and then I
upgraded it to 64 kilobytes of memory
so so I've been playing with computers
and electronics from a very
young age
and what I've learned over the year is
that the ability to take technology and
turn it into something
viable functional that people want and
need and solves people's life
is what excites me sounds a little bit
like a cliche but seeing lots of people
use your technology and get excited
about it use your product actually is
what excites me
interesting and so so there's a
technology side there's the product side
the the connection piece of it and
specifically you you decided to dedicate
a lot of your time to renewable energy
where did that come from I mean today
everybody's talking about it obviously
but back then I don't think it was as
you know as mainstream as today or as at
least on the surface as it is today tell
me a little bit about your your founding
of solarage
so
we got into renewable energy
by chance
not like we said okay we're gonna do a
renewable energy company
we were five friends we said we'll start
something and we looked for ideas pretty
much everywhere and
numerous markets not
I don't want to even to say no Just
Energy because he didn't even look at
energy
and throughout that a ideation process
we got into the understanding that
there's a revolution in power and
electronics and that there is a
digitization of the Power Electronics
fields
and we developed this technology around
batteries and in in power management in
laptops and mobile devices
nobody would invest in that every
investor we met was like very nice but
no thank you until one investor told us
that the technology looks very very cool
but the market is a is a competitive red
ocean type of Market
in that it would be very hard to create
a huge success in this market
and then we just looked at markets where
we can
move our technology into
and guy which was one of the founders
and the CEO when we built the list he
said solar energy is going to be a big
thing let's let's explore that
was by no means even number five on the
list it was somewhere around number 15
18.
but we looked at that first and it and
we found that there's a huge Market that
we need this disruption we're going good
for the the planet and for mankind
we moved all our efforts there and
that's how solid was created all right
and so just a little bit about solar
energy and and renewable energy the
space that you were in what were sort of
the key insights that now having gone
through the process IQ et cetera what
you know what what do we know or what
did you learn
um about the space so when when we
started there were two things that you
could easily see about the market a
solar energy was very expensive yeah
I'll just give you the metric when we
started in 2006 solar panels where
sold at around 14 a what fourteen
dollars a lot that's really really
expensive compared to the price today
which is around 20 something cents a
walk
solar energy was really expensive
and the field was very basic very
rudimentary it would just connect the
solar panels in strings
my Christmas lights in in some way and
connect them to a to a power conversion
device which was very was very good in
the conversion efficiency what but very
basic in all other aspects not web
connected not sophisticated at all
and we realized that this is a market
that is going to grow significantly
because everybody said it's gonna go and
it was clear that the planet needed and
that we can bring one of our destruction
into the system side and and the power
and electronic size and web connection
now fast forward
I want to pause it for a second so
you're mentioning that you have clear
conviction of where this industry is
heading and and the growth of it not
just from a from again economically but
you know it's just clear Society is this
is this a conviction that that everybody
has around you so yeah so yeah so well
that's exactly what what I wanted to say
so you fast forward this 17 years into
the future until now solar energy is the
cheapest cost of energy there is no way
of making energy which is cheaper
competing with nuclear nuclear is also
very cheap and so solid energy is
Furniture Fair be abundant right so
there is a sort of penetration into our
view this is clear in in most places
around the world means a lot of other
advantages because it is distributed
generation so it solves a lot of issues
with the distribution grid
and the technology advancement is simply
used so we moved from
just blinking connection web connection
into solar systems today solar systems
are great connected in a sense that they
communicate with each other they have
storage and backup and like these cool
things called virtual power plants when
thousands of tens of thousands of solar
systems operate as one large virtual
power plant that the field has advanced
so much it will be a major source of
energy for mankind it is already a major
source it will be even larger
and so the conviction that we had now
like in 2006 is
it's clear to see it now interesting
okay so you know you go through the the
whole journey that every entrepreneur's
dream with with solar engine and where
do you find yourself in your in your own
Journey so what what are the things that
that you're sort of thinking to yourself
or the different expectations or or
different things that you now want to
bring to the world
so
so my journey with with solar Ridge was
overall
s to 15 years and and and
it was amazing because every two years
the company evolved we started as a team
doing only RND and then at some point I
was tasked with finding design partners
and convincing them to work with us so
that was very interesting for me as a as
an engineer to start doing some business
stuff and for design Partners to move to
actually structuring product in business
and look for a bit doing sales and from
that we we moved to to the point where
we needed to be a global company in the
sense that we are
telling multiple countries and then
sales scale up and then a family company
and then a going public company every
two years something something new fairly
interesting for me all that with
continuously developing technology and
products
and after 15 years
companies now very very loud and sell
their billions of dollars and makes and
profit or Fair of hundreds of millions
of dollars and I transitioned out
and I'm still involved in Solo Virginia
in a consultancy world to the management
but
what I do now and my passion now is the
early stage Venture Capital investing
basically trying to recreate
that that experience with by meeting new
teams and
it's amazing because I get to see the
future like five times a week
some of these things I get the privilege
of investing and then I try to give them
from my experience
as board members and say friend as an
investor to help them move in a similar
direction or in a similar path that
we've seen at some of it right and so
what what things are you most excited by
today when you meet teams or is it in
different Technologies different types
of people what what are you know what is
your sweet spot in terms of how you like
to spend your time so so
people is everything right and and and
and and besides both people first and
and
for my inform inform other Journeys what
I know so it is that
finding the right team a team that is on
one end coachable on the other hand is
strong and independent that's the key to
successful startups that's the key to to
success
you know as a company
so the first thing I look when I see any
team is is how good is the team how good
is the Chemistry Between the team
members and what is the combination of
capabilities that they have as a team
in terms of
um things that I like to invest so if if
you look at the growth portfolio you
would see that around third of our
portfolio is what we call vertical SAS
it's always places where there is
vertical part of the market where there
is one for absorption either because
there are new data sets
all because there is a new way of
utilizing that data so
if I invested in an AI company that is
leveraging proteomic data for drug
Discovery so there's new data sets in
the newer AI models and now you can take
the new AI models and the new data sets
and the slabs found so that's one
example of our vertical AI strategy in
in things that excite me a storm theme
in a vertical where there is a good
Market but also something that's changed
dramatically either in the availability
of data or the the the algorithms that
process that data another third of our
portfolio is infrastructure so obviously
in infrastructure I look at climate and
and energy because these are fields that
I am strong Affinity to and strongly
understanding but also the entire
infrastructure stack of of data centers
in Cloud
you know people are so excited with a
generative AI I'm excited with
generative
AI I'm still not sure what's the play
there for startups but for sure the
companies that are going to make the
most money at least initially from
generative AI are the beta Center
companies the cloud infrastructure
company
so when we look at
at infrastructure companies that excite
us
and the third of our portfolio is Edge
compute at the edge sensing at the edge
communication and at the edge
there's still a lot of things to disturb
because too much of our data is captured
at the edge has been sent for processing
in the cloud
and very cost effective in energy it's
very cost effective in a computer if we
could do more of that at the edge
there are a lot of interesting
opportunities there interesting and so
you know you're mentioning a variety of
things obviously all of them are
surrounding deep technology and and it
sounds like a it's a deep technology in
various domains and so you have to
really you know be sort of be the main
expert how how are you either lures or
as a fund how do you navigate you know
being able to to play with these domain
expertise around these different
verticals because they require an
internal thesis to to be aligned with a
thesis of obviously the entrepreneurs
and you know all these I I don't imagine
that there's a unanimous thoughts around
or any of these industries and and so
how do you operate within this world of
uncertainty in three different connected
but different deep Tech domains so so
there are two layers right so if you
look at the specific company in a
specific technological Lane
so unrealistic to believe that we would
have the Deep technology and
understanding so we use experts
but what I think is more important is a
the ability to understand the technology
to a certain depth and then to layer
that with the core and deep
understanding we have of the markets
because technology is great but as I
started the product is more important
for the startup success the product
Market fit is more important the
direction that the market is taking
you would have to have
mind-blowing technology and
I'm a seller that startups really have
mind-blowing technology
Nobel Prize level so usually if you're
going against the market direction if
you're going against what the customers
need the best technology won't get to
you into a great company so our ability
to know the markets to behave within the
markets to understand them will these
markets are going to be in touch with
the customers and understand what they
need
what helps us select the companies in
the specific
Fields yes there is we need to
understand technology because otherwise
we don't even know how to recognize a
good company but at a certain level we
need experts and we
always bring experts for the technology
due diligence layer but I must tell you
that's really the most important layer
do you
and then product and the ability for
that technology to disrupt the market
very cool so if we're looking a couple
years into the future you're a
technologist at heart entrepreneur
investor and obviously forward thinker
having given the first uh part of this
conversation where what what are you
most excited about what are some things
that are potentially you know keeping
you up at night that you know that
really resonate with you
so I'll start with where we started
energy and climate clearly there's a
crisis side the crisis it's not just the
the global warming crisis which I have
no doubt that that we are leaving
through it
and there's also an energy crisis coming
from the fact that we consume more and
more energy because there's an energy
shift in the way that we in the way that
we consume energy I'll just give you one
example but there are many more electric
vehicles the world is clearly moving
towards electric vehicles because of
many reasons not just climate
and people don't understand that but
electric vehicles are part of the grid
they are moving
power stations that you can charge at
home and discharge at work in the in the
other way around they're part of the
Grid it's a distraction of the financial
model electric vehicles are
they take up less they spell about so
it's a huge financial disruption for for
auto companies usually auto companies
are now thinking of how they can be part
of the energy plane so energy and
climate wow
these two I can talk about for hours the
the the initially let me I will
the changing of the market the changing
of the four of the financial models the
technology that is needed the amount of
data points that are needed to make
decisions around our grade it's
mind-boggling so yes I'm very bullish on
energy specific energy types of
companies and I think that because of
the cow of the global warming crisis
they would be Market disruption in
climate and carbon so these are two
Fields then comes data centers or data
in general right we are the the growth
of of data consumption and data storage
for mankind is huge which means that new
data sets that will stop things and lots
of lots of data centers
whether they're on the edge or in the
cloud that we need to to possess that
I don't think we've even started the
tapping into that potential
and there are a few other things that
excite us as a fan for example the the
the the disruption in healthcare that
started before coffee then covered they
accelerated
bio
genomics autonomics it's a very
interesting one I love it and and I
think that what most resonates through
this conversation is obviously how how
passionate you are about what you do and
how excited you are about the different
aspects and I think it's um it's it's
really it's really fun for me to sit and
listen to how you can talk so excitedly
about the Technologies you were building
and then the the from a business
perspective a leadership perspective
growing their organizations and you
mentioned how every two years you had
sort of this different cycle of
innovation within the organization and
the growth and then talking about how
you're actually expanding it to work
with different teams in different
capacities and not you know on a
specific or vertical but on three
different big big domains that require
you know a lot of thesis building on
your end but then a lot of conviction
and and a lot partnership with teams and
obviously then spending time to think
about where we're headed you know as a
world and what the future is like and so
it just sounds like you're you're having
a blast and I I really want to thank you
for spending these 20 minutes with me
thank you very much thank you very very
much
foreign
[Music]